i'm so excited i haven't done something
like this in so long because of 2020 and
i get to drink
well happy holidays miss lily singh
thank you
i like forgot it was the holidays i've
been but you're right it is in fact the
holidays you are correct happy holidays
who knows what day of the week it is but
i do know we are ready to say goodbye to
2020 and
you my friend are ringing in the new
year in a big way
what can you tell us i can tell you all
the things i can tell you that i'm so
excited to be
hosting this bud light seltzer session
for new year's eve
um i haven't done something like this in
so long because of 2020
and i have all this pent up energy and
so you're gonna see a very energetic
me while hosting this event um and i get
to drink
you do i do okay well i also want to
know
what you get to wear because it is held
virtually like on the waist up are you
going to be in that new year's eve flare
and then sweats
or what no no i'm going to be in sweats
the whole time because
my the whole body will be in sweat i'm
on a perfect
strict authenticity and comfort diet
where i will only be comfortable and
myself and myself is probably going to
be in some sort of
oversized tracksuit what is new year's
eve typically like for you you know this
is a huge deal for me i'd like to have a
certain vibe to my new year's eve but
this year's been an exception i actually
jumped at this opportunity because
like i said this year has been different
and i haven't got to have too many of
these exciting
live-ish hosting moments um so i feel
really really good about this and
i think this is the absolute perfect way
i'd want to bring in this year it kind
of like
this is what we're going to go into 2021
with more of this
right and then hopefully maintain this
exactly and then hopefully not go back
to my house for another year hopefully
leave my house again
i'm still in my four walls hopefully i
get up but
thankfully we have shows like yours to
keep us entertained um and i know that
season two of your late night talk show
uh hits january 11th that's the premiere
with an all-new look
what can you tell us about that i can
tell you that like i said it's it's
a whole lot of me you know i think i'm
bringing my full authentic self to late
night
uh and i don't want to have it any other
way i want to be in perfect i want to be
me i want to
talk about things i think are funny and
true and you'll see that in season two
welcome to the first episode of a little
late with lily singh
what was the biggest lesson you would
say you learned in that first season
i think in season one as much as i
wanted to front in interviews and be
like i'm gonna be
me and not listen to the pressures i
absolutely listen to the pressures i
absolutely
um made comments and monologues or like
made jokes and monologues that i'm like
oh this is not really authentic and i
don't know if it's that funny but i'm
going to say it because hopefully it's
funny i think i'll get a
let a lot of the headlines and voices
get in my head um and i'm just i'm
learning to not
let that happen again it's a work in
progress but i'm learning to just
really give myself permission to do me
and to still have
fun right exactly fun is actually
crucial thank you for bringing that up
fun so crucial which is another reason
i'm i'm so excited about new year's eve
because
i don't know if i mention this i get to
drink i get to drink a mango
bud light salsa and i get to work and as
an indian the mango also makes me very
happy
so it's all of my favorite things
combined and i'm very brand
very on brand i love to see it for sure
well you know um on that first season of
your show you had a lot of famous guests
on there
john legend mindy kaling charlie
starring you know
like feedless people uh no is there
anyone left
on your dream guest list um of course
you know i
i had a lot of people on the show that
were really great friends of mine but i
didn't get to have all of them you know
i didn't get to have priyanka chopra i
didn't get to have dwayne johnson
because of scheduling
and also if i'm very honest that's
talking about celebrities
but i'm also very interested in having
people who are not necessarily
traditional celebrities but are doing
dope things
i'm very intrigued to just i just want
to have good conversations you know
i want to talk about people who are
doing good things for the community who
are
innovative who um haven't gotten their
shot on a late night show yet i want to
have those conversations so i'm very
excited about that
some deep ones too i'm sure personal i
mean
you've always been such a great
storyteller you know and i know that
this year a lot of focus for a lot of
people has been on
mental health how have you been checking
in with yourself and your well-being and
your mental health
during these times especially when i
mean you're still working you know
you're still busy
yeah i think mental health is so
important especially this past year like
you mentioned
something i've been doing more is this
is a very specific thing but i've been
practicing the
art of taking back control i've realized
through pandemic that
a lot of the silver lining has been that
i've learned a lot of the reasons i'm
ever upset or stressed is because i'm
giving my control away to something
more often than not it's social media
and so i've tried to just
create some balance in my life between
myself and the things that have
previously consumed me
so you know i don't have social media on
my phone anymore i tried to really
talk to myself before i go to bed i try
to check in with myself i try to
meditate so
it's it's become very important
especially this year when you look back
on this year though what will you
remember the most
oh what will i remember the most what's
the highlight for lily seeing in 2020
i mean listen i i this is always an
interesting question because this year
has been so
tough and so it always feels so awkward
to be like but this amazing thing
happened but you know i i don't want to
dismiss the accomplishments i did have
because i do believe in celebrating them
um i'm very proud of the work i've done
on my show thus far for season two we're
just in the process of shooting
um you know i got to release a really
cool comedy special called sketchy times
which i was very very proud of and i
continued to be proud of and
on a personal note i moved i moved at
the beginning of lockdown and i know
that's
a strange thing but it was so unique to
me because
moving during a literal lockdown is a
unique experience i have not had
furniture for the past
seven months like i haven't had a couch
i don't have any furniture and so it's
been a very
humbling experience for me uh living in
that house so that's been
something i'll definitely remember
you're literally starting on a clean
slate
huh 100 i right now have a weighted
blanket on my floor that i use as the
couch
um it's it's okay luxury
i love it um you know obviously it has
been a tough year
but i do want to think about the
positives and you know what is something
that has made you laugh
or brought you a sense of joy this past
year
i think one of the silver linings of
lockdown is that we saw a lot of
creators come to life or be birthed
because a lot of people started
streaming and started posting on social
media more
so a lot of creators that have got that
i watch daily now or people i discovered
during
the pandemic elsa majimbo is a prime
example i just honored her at the
streamy awards as well
um she's a comedian from kenya who's
just incredible who knows if it wasn't
for
lockdown maybe she wouldn't have picked
up the camera as much and done what she
does
um so so that has been really helping me
through rough times and i think art in
general
you know it's been such a beautiful
silver lining because
we've all turned to art we turned to
film we turned to tv we've turned to
music and i think
uh it's really shown exactly and tick
tock
and we've it just shows us how important
all being creative
is you know so that's been really
beautiful for me
for sure and finally so what i mean i've
never been
a new year's resolution guy mainly
because i don't like to put that kind of
pressure
or set myself for disappointment but um
you know i feel like
this next year i think goal setting is
so key for a lot of people
have you set any goals or intentions for
yourself in
life love and career for next year
yes i have that i just made up right now
based on this question
um yeah that's the thing you said
because i've been thinking a lot about
it as well to be honest and that is
i really want to prioritize having fun
i have just learned through the last 10
years of my career that
you can work really really hard and that
is very important and
you can pull the all-nighters when you
have to and yeah you can applaud that
but if you're
if you do all that and you look back and
you go i didn't have fun
none of it is worth it you have to if
you're gonna work so hard you have to
have fun and so
whether it's season two whether it is my
youtube channel
whether it is hosting bud light seltzer
sessions for new year's eve i'm going to
have
fun doing it because these moments have
to count and i
i actually am going to put the same
resolution on people watching i'm going
to force this resolution on you what you
should do on new year's eve you should
grab your own bud light saucer
you should join in and watch this epic
live show because i'm telling you all of
my energy will be there because it is
pent up so let's have fun
together fun that should be the
resolution fun you better preach i mean
what's more fun than getting drunk in
your sweats with lily sing
i'm just saying nothing